I was watching a porn the other day and
the director whoever is the camera guy
amazing or what it wasn't great he
reaches his hand in and adjusts the
lady's leg in the middle of the scene
number one you cut also number two it if
I was the girl I would do a Christian
baale like how could you come into my
scene yeah and interrupt my [__] you
know what I mean I'm not working with
you I would [__] go crazy yeah yeah
yeah if somebody adjusted your life no
there's actually a lot of times like
when I'm in gang bangs like the last
gang bang I did I was getting stop what
is that a gang bang what do you mean
please please please please please a g a
gang bang is when I get [__] by a
minimum of five guys is that the most
you've done no the most the most you've
done the most in a gang bang is 11 and
the most in a blow bang is 15 wait but a
minimum for gang bang is always five
five that's aim what you call four it's
not a gang bang it's like a group
scene you were in a gang bang a blow
bang a blow bang you're going to the
eighth [__] yes and the ninth [__] was
me yes be real yes would you laugh no
you wouldn't know I don't even I
surprised you but they don't they don't
prep you like you're just going through
it and Bobby just up you going to tell
it's me because I'm wearing the be offit
yeah and he has he's squeezing a juice
yeah yeah yeah and I'm making juice yeah
but I I I would think that you and I
would have a connection you would laugh
no I would I'd probably come up and kiss
you all that really on the mouth yeah
that means you kiss seven dude's [__]
yeah
oh oh yeah holy moly but it would be
such a good kiss it'd be such a good
kiss but you already sucked you know I
mean yeah it's a
sweet sweet it's a little bit of dread
one of these I like my baby yeah
something's in my mouth I right it's a
part of somebody else has come that's
fine they they won't have come yet right
right okay it would just be pre-come and
spit and here's another thing I don't
like about gangbangs yeah is when the
guys are joking around you don't want
them to have fun or talking amongst each
other no yeah man hey man it's not
[__] Indie 500 like they'll do jokes
bad writing you just not the bad writing
no they improvise it's like shut the
[__] up oh I'm busy yeah go get him Tony
like I don't want to know oh like when
they're egging each other on yeah I
don't like yeah yeah Tony that's how you
know what I mean like all right let Tony
Focus you know what I
mean dude you got some person
I do I have personal things in porn yeah
yeah what I don't like yeah so
um did are they respectful though yes
are those yes unless you want them to
not be respectful oh are you one of
those you like it well yeah I do
especially in a gang bang that's like
the perfect time for it to be how rough
though what's your
scale from like sometimes sometimes when
I'm watching that I have to turn it off
and go that was too much okay you know
what I mean I don't like it what's the
line what's the hard line for you blood
oh yeah no yeah yeah blood's blood's a
big one blood's a big big one for a lot
of us pretty standard why you rolling
your eyes I'm not it's a big one for me
it is a big one for everyone yeah yeah
when there open will laceration yeah not
you're not what are you watching what
what are you watching I'm just saying I
like I don't like it before every scene
we go over like our hard nose and our
do's and don't I'm a production meeting
yeah right here we go hello who are you
I'm the producer and director okay
what's your name huh what's your name
Benjamin
diei Benjamin diei world renowned
director
Benjamin I'm Benjamin taii you don't
know oh I know well then why'd you ask
just wanted to hear can we do the
meeting yes all right so what are your
dudes and don'ts in the uh rough scale
uh well wait wait wait are we are we so
we're on set right now and I'm doing
what kind of scene a gang bang we're
doing a violent gang
bang it's what Benjamin die wait is that
too much the language we wouldn't never
we would never do like a violent gang
because if it's rough and it's
consensual it's not violence let me my
terminology was wrong we're doing a
rough gang bang sure there we go and
what are your dos and Tes okay so I'm
okay with hair pulling I'm okay with
face slapping I'm okay with spanking I'm
okay with spit well Tony yeah the guy
that's going to you know last time we
did he pulled the hair out of the scalp
not that not that hard too much too much
that's what I'm saying I want to be
specific yeah yeah and also like does it
matter where he's pulling from cuz I
don't like my hair pulled from here I
like it P pulled from the scalp yeah
pulling from the scalp yeah okay well
Tony yeah
[Music]
no thanks Tony oh man yeah it's okay
tone so anyway so no scal pulling right
okay good what else um so and also with
any slapping no bruising so you can slap
me but not so hard that you're going to
bruise me m you're you're Bruiser yes
I'm a Bruiser